I was always conscious at my job was
from an estimated so I was prepared to
risk when I we didn't matter with the
next year and mytouch anyone could play
a game of football anyone the practice
makes your football you know it was
devoted to been the best it can be . our
problem how you deal with a problem and
if you don't deal with that then you
feel again I think of energy in this and
then listen to this is really important
i think that the example was saying that
was important to them say well if you
can do I can do it people don't respond
to change
well when they see someone management is
changing his mind of a second day or
your attitude should be
I've got my chance someone this world
I'm gonna succeed he said yourself you
could not be that way like you know 27
years in prison coming have no business
at all
he's a former scottish football manager
and player who manage Manchester United
is regarded as one of the greatest
football managers of all time during his
26 years of Manchester United he won 38
trophies
he's sir alex ferguson and hear his top
ten rules for success
how would a chief executive manager risk
for a football coach I was always
conscious that former job offers from an
estimated so I was prepared to risk
shove defenders up in the attacking
positions take the game because it was
too nothing still lost anyway you know I
think there's a common sense attitude
from from good we just that is it worth
the risk but we're going to lose it to
this one thing that United were the best
that they were better than the
consistency when that we didn't matter
with the next year
Martin and there's not many teams can
continue without foreign city when the
week was there next year next year
she'll say over the spell I know them in
a bad spell is very difficult to
maintain a success i can continue
successful five six seven years very
very old and what was the thing that
allowed you to do it where so many other
people have had challenges doing that
whether they're running a company or
running a football club
well as as I complacency to avoid
complacency that if you want a week my
first steps the next season was to
remind them about many things to
expectation about the responsibilities
that complacency is is a disease that
all these things matter to me because I
was always fearful of dropping back off
the scale
mhm and force way we had them where they
a reasonable consistency but the most
important thing about united for me was
that every time we were lost the week
and the provision we went in the next
year so those other spawns by the
character of the team that's what's
really important development character
and the football team is just as
important as development that the
ability of the team and the character
that football club was very very strong
very strong characters me and I think
that is really important
the advice I give to any young kid as
anyone can play a game of football
anyone the practice makes your football
you see games in a Sunday up games
oh well they gave a football the real
players of that practice anything about
and when you take that I remember being
at once in glasgow many many years ago
and got a player was a physical the
color golfer and they asked him that
question why do you keep practice and
from the bunker because it was famous
for your uncle says well and all I'm
going to be the bend the bunker at one
time in the game maybe twice in a game
and I've got to put in a whole is as
we're practice and practice and practice
that's a great example we go there we
have to do to get a lot where all the
sacrifices you have to make as a leader
i think i read in your book that you you
played football the day you got married
there
mr. burns of one of your son's at least
what do you have to make any sacrifices
to be a winning chief executive
absolutely there's no other way
yes he was devoted to been the basic can
be and also an example to everyone so
sacrifices absolute its Parliament
absolute to me absolute Parliament go to
achievements that are not big 10 and
feeling your problem how you deal with a
problem and if you don't deal with that
then you feel again I always feel that
advance that is always drive in
manchester united on we don'twe losing
and therefore the human beings you go I
know that character we've got in the
dressing room has to come to the surface
and moments where we have watched again
to think of energy in this in and when
listen to this is really important when
you stop wave i did the United we see 43
44 years of age to see the energy the
percy the NGC bonus and over here but
when you get to the six is this still
expect to see it often so i had to look
at myself in terms of energy that was
swept because when i was a young major
for five years
no problem when I got to that to my
sixties and it is six or seven nose so
you go ahead there where you work it you
have your day better Saturday swallow
after the game on home
you know I never had a very very seldom
known as laminate so that added things
are myself of a manager because people
want to see the energy really important
aspect of it if you were running a
business and it was a business winning
team what characteristics would you have
to see my staff and receive them come in
there in the morning mother was good
ready fresh the same purposes me
hard-working energetic good
personalities and we built a bigger
staff in terms of the physical therapist
and sports sciences things that they
start to come in the same time as me so
I think that the example was saying
there was important to them say well if
you can do I can do i buy things
important things to what I i think is
reported to be consistent be who you are
don't change I think people don't
respond to change
well when they see some of the minor bit
is changing his mind of a second do
whatever I think consistency really
important i don't think they should
whatever the number of people who
qualify the same time ism that's why
negative you know that thing is here
shit up by the hundreds apply i'll never
gather you know I don't think that's a
positive attitude your attitude should
be
I've got my chance someone this world
I'm gonna succeed and want to play for
the job you know something which is
really important person get as many
interviews you can you know that
technique of going from interviews
nothing only you know you can get a
hundred and using your field names you
improve through interviewing and at some
point away if you may be interviewing
someone else you're a great student of
leaders historical political who has
some of the leaders you admire him for
what qualities nelson mandela the great
thing about was that was optional
bitterness is attached to his life and
he said yourself what could I be that
way that you know 27 years in prison
color have no business at all was
interesting was making south africa i
can today be recognized and go in there
a moral path
thank you so much for watching I made
this beauty because high-low asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do i also love to know which of stocks
Ferguson's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
i know CeCe
over the bar in the second possibly
feeling that he said a couple of very
good chances hasn't taken either just a
tour know that wonderful defending
lately
still nothing each quarter of thoughts
and flaming going up viewers therefore
mother always has been so often asked in
the model defense positively racing out
know what comes across Pegasus school
united huzi
wasn't even able to look at the linesman
less of a picture of the linesman that
you are right
this conversation should certainly be
interesting
rightfully coming over to the lines
woman
plays with talking to the ramp
this is official moment in this match
so Alex Ferguson's all is good
all came across
Ferguson
last time we did the defense that is
right in the middle of your picture
find with five minutes to play
a controversial goal
but one that counts
united lead by one goal to know Alex
Ferguson
scores his sixth goal of the season